la quasi-totalité des mines du négoce
est détenu par les sri lankais à 80% il
n'aime pas trop parler de leurs affaires
est ce que c'est un bon endroit ici oui
c'est un bon endroit aussi pourquoi il
ya des saphirs dans beaucoup d'endroits
pour en savoir plus sur les coulisses tu
ce business nous sommes retournés voir
mark snow veraz
lui aussi vit ici depuis 14 ans il a
appris le malgache
il est 7 heures du matin comme chaque
jour marque s'installe à la fenêtre de
son magasin pour acheter des pierres
l'ambiance est loin de la frénésie
d'avant
ok on sait combien c'est moi je te la
fais à 450 aux 3,5 euros 450 lots
dis moi combien la croissance
35 euros non ça n'ira pas je vais
demander 50 fois la valeur que l'on veut
réellement donc ça va faire l'objet
d'une négociation
c'est finalement à l'acheteur de donner
son offre
en général je ne donne aucun prix
si l'avant et la pierre est vendu tant
mieux c'est raté non 25
ok je reviens
marque cherche la belle pierre celle
qu'il pourra vendre aux plus grands
joailliers ce ne sera pas pour
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
pour essaiera ce soir de racheter
quelques pierres puisqu'il apparemment
il n'y a plus grand chose
il en a tout de même acheté six de
qualité moyenne pour 130 euros du moment
on a au moins une pierre on va
considérer qu'on a quelque chose on
attend quand même des jours meilleurs ou
avec des pierres plus importantes ou de
plus grande valeur on va dire que s'il
n'y a pas vraiment de rareté il faudra
faire un assemblage avec plusieurs
pierres pour pouvoir les mettre en
valeur ses des pierres j'espère qu'une
fois taillé on pourra vendre le double
pente il ne peut pas exporter ses saphir
il les vend aux touristes de passage
avec philippe son associé français il a
embauché trois malgaches pour fabriquer
des bijoux sur place
vols apporte une valeur ajoutée mais on
leur en vendent à blanc
aucun promoteur comme ça ce qu'on va
chercher à faire c'est épouser la forme
du brut pour garder un maximum de poids
on va les polir pour qu'elle ait un
aspect brillant comme du verre
ces artisans malgaches ont tous été
formés par marc ils sont précis et aussi
compétents que les tailleurs suisse il
leur faudra plus de trois heures pour
ciseler une des pierres acheter ce jour
là elle sera vendue 120 euros dans son
magasin
marks a tenu à nous emmener là où tout a
commencé
à la sortie de la ville la première mine
dit la caq celle de gaz par la banque
suisse sur le sur la banque sus des
premières mines travail et aïda cac qui
correspond à l'ancien lit de la rivière
et la quête
d'un vin comme
une gigantesque carrière à ciel ouvert
désormais propriété d'entrepreneurs sri
lankais
aujourd'hui il faut creuser à plus de 50
mètres de profondeur pour trouver des
saphirs
ce qu'était en surface tout ce qui était
facile d'accès a été ramassé je pense
que d'essayer une année ou deux tout
sera terminé ici on aura aura tous
travailler
en attendant la fin du saphir haï la cac
la bonne fortune d'un tout petit nombre
continue de faire rêver
mais pour beaucoup l'ancienne ville
champignon posé au milieu du désert
n'aura été qu'un mirage
[Musique]